ils sont plusieurs centaines à vivre
dans ce campement de paint city près du
cap
ceux-ci temporaire a été mis en place
tant dans le confinement du à la
pandémie de covile 19 pour abriter les
réfugiés sans abri et combattre la
propagation du virus
ceux qui vivent dénoncent leurs
conditions de vie et plus généralement
le traitement des demandeurs d'asile en
afrique du sud victimes selon ne de
xénophobie
nous vivons dans la peur mes enfants
vivent dans la peur nous ressentons tous
de la peur en tant que réfugiés nous ne
sommes pas en sécurité en afrique du sud
nous sommes vraiment des victimes c'est
ici que nous vivons maintenant c'est
pour ça que nous protestons c'est pour
ça que nous souffrons je suis du
bangladesh
j'ai eu un problème avec la politique au
bangladesh c'est pour ça que je suis ici
en afrique du sud pour rester en vie
mais quand je suis venu ici en afrique
du sud
j ai trouvé beaucoup de xénophobie et
subi de nombreuses attaques depuis 2008
je ne me sens donc pas en sécurité en
afrique du sud non plus c'est pour ça
que je veux quitter l'afrique du sud
parmi les causes du sentiment
d'insécurité qu'éprouvent les réfugiés
il y a le sentiment que le gouvernement
sud africain ne fait rien pour les
protéger
certains d'entre eux réclament le
soutien des nations unies
le gouvernement sud africain a échoué à
protéger les réfugiés dans ce pays nous
mourrons tous les jours ils pillent nos
magasins ils interdisent à nos proches
de vivre tant de choses qui se sont
produites en afrique du sud que nous ne
sommes pas en sécurité
le gouvernement sud africain le sait
mais il ne fait rien pour nous protéger
nos conditions de vie ont empiré
nous sommes très nombreux avec des
enfants des mamans souffrent ici
maintenant il faut que les nations unies
le haut commissariat aux réfugiés nous
aide nous sommes très nombreux et nous
en ferons nos frères sont en train de
souffrir
il faut vraiment qu'ils nous aident il
n'y a rien ici pour vivre comme des
êtres humains avec près de 60 millions
d'habitants l'afrique du sud est l'un
des pays les plus touchés par la
pandémie de kovy 19 et les conséquences
se font sentir aussi bien sur le plan
sanitaire que sur le plan économique
selon le haut commissariat des nations
unies pour les réfugiés
et de 270 mille réfugiés vivent dans le
pays mais il y aurait en réalité de cinq
cent mille à un million d'étrangers sans
papiers en afrique du sud